the State Department abruptly closed the
US consulate in Playa del Carmen Mexico
and is prohibiting all US government
employees from traveling to the resort
town government sources tell CBS News
this is because of a real crime threat
connected to warring drug cartels a
security alert is now in effect for all
Americans and a Warner is here with what
this means for people visiting the
popular tourist destination quite a
headline and a good morning yeah good
morning Playa del Carmen of course is at
the heart of Mexico's Riviera Maya on
the Yucatan Peninsula not far from other
tourist hotspots like Cozumel Cancun and
Tulum the area may seem like a tropical
paradise but it has not been spared the
violence sweeping other parts of the
country an explosion on a tourist ferry
last month in playa del carmen injured
at least five US citizens undetonated
bombs were found on another vessel owned
by the same ferry company less than two
weeks later and in January of last year
a shooting at a Playa del Carmen
nightclub killed five people including
an American teen who was trampled while
trying to escape over the past year
there has been a dramatic increase in
violence in and around Playa del Carmen
according to Eric Olsen an expert on
security issues in Mexico there are
American victims but they tend to be
bystanders people in the wrong place at
the wrong time
the US Embassy did not mention a
specific plot targeting Americans but
Olson believes issuing the security
alert was the right call there's
information that there could be a
violent attack in the next few days so
they are letting people know what they
know and so I think people should take
that seriously
he says 2017 was Mexico's deadliest year
on record with nearly 30,000 murders in
January the State Department issued a
travel ban to five Mexican states
Americans visiting other parts of the
country including Quint annaroo where
Playa del Carmen is located are only
urged to use increased caution but the
number of foreign visitors to Playa del
Carmen jumped more than 18 percent last
year and CBS News travel editor Peter
Greenberg says the number of Americans
killed in violent crimes and
Mexico is very small every time the
United States issues a travel advisory
it's got such a negative connotation
there's an immediate knee-jerk reaction
for people to cancel but in terms of
Americans being targeted for violent
crime doesn't really exist
well Canada updated its travel advisory
from Mexico urging its citizens to
exercise a high degree of caution the
Mexico Tourism Board insists Playa del
Carmen is safe it tells CBS this morning
the u.s. security alert implies safety
issues without any basis in fact but
goes without saying I think that you
need to be careful in highly touristed
areas yeah and its brain earache
everybody's doing some travel right and
college kids need to watch out for what
they're doing
Thank You Adam a lot of nervous people
looking at their plans again